hey what's up everyone just got out of
watching Ant-Man on the WASP quantumania
right there fresh out of the theater and
what did everybody think of it
wow so there was a lot and that two
hours plus just fly by flies by and it's
easily placed taste but God I'm so
excited I'm fumbling my words this is a
movie you're gonna have to see multiple
times I thought the movie was great I
love the action I love the cinema the uh
the cgia it seems like the Marvel bumped
up their game
[Music]
oh he's amazing
he's absolutely I don't care if he's
evil he is so hot
um
but no uh the movie the movie CGI was
stunning it was it they really went all
out in creating the quantum realm
um the story like a little bit
underwhelming but like I like the pacing
and I love what they you know you know I
love I love Salt Lake so I love the
family of yeah
it's hard not to love Ant-Man it really
is hard not to love Ant-Man I mean
Baskin Robbins
what's going on there's a lot of amazing
scenes in it it is really big
um this isn't a review so we're not
gonna say but I really really enjoyed
the movie it was exciting uh I will say
post credit scenes uh had me jumping
onto my seat and I think that's what
everyone's going to be talking about
after the movie is the post-credit
scenes but they're trying to tell the
very very
you won't be disappointed with this
movie you will not be disappointed with
post credits
King is so hot
Jonathan Majors for me stole the show I
mean Paul Wright of course Paul Rudd I
love Paul ruddle you can't really steal
it from him oh yeah they're all really
wrong with Michael Douglas and the whole
team and it's funny because you can you
can tell at one point that this was us
who filmed before uh creep three so yeah
Jonathan Majors was
a moment where you're like oh that's
left over from his stream oh for sure oh
yeah for sure what I will say he was
both in Lovecraft country okay we lost
the show these are beautiful like
there's nothing like I seriously Karen
could use a lot I don't care they pass
perfect for him I will say that it's a
perfect casting absolutely perfect he is
King many lands and all of his variants
that are in heat Rings whatever it's
perfect he was perfect he was Kane and
this movie was just pretty awesome and a
really really fun ride yeah can't wait
for everybody to watch it